[Music]
in unfortunate events news Oh David
submitted by at you
a man was stuck in quicksand for hours
then had to brave a winter storm were
than that in a movie the guy's name is
achoo birth the foot Chinese are Chu I
was like a sneeze and it was like that
became somebody's name actually
I didn't ask for his name I asked for
yours gieux aren't you aren't you that
sounds like a racist joke
how did the Chinese guy King his name
was he a Chinese guy okay keep going
so this dude is in quicksand but they
were saying that the quicksand and the
storm the guy's name was that you in a
movie so I got confused I always try to
make quick sound as a kid me too
I always pretended like the sandbox was
quicksand you ever fill it up with water
and try to make it into quick slant yeah
yeah I would carry the water in my mouth
and then me and my friends we would do
that because we didn't have cups or
anything and we look at each other why
then we laugh and we weren't enough ever
making oh you got making our backyard
you got to get a hole that said you got
to get a hose that do quick turn there's
three four year old man and a woman he
was with they were hiking and died on
national parking you I wanna go there it
looks beautiful
we should try the egg waffle in there
they have quicksand there so that's why
um this man's leg got stuck in quicksand
you're not supposed to panic right your
sausage so they do have this hand there
yeah so apparently it's impossible for
you to drown and quick that like for you
to get below the surface impossible if
you don't move but if you're struggling
yeah I chewed then you can somehow like
you know [ __ ] up and then drop she could
be like this so he's gotta show that if
you get caught in it yeah just wait help
help help
yeah so luckily he was with someone so
this woman she was height she hiked out
for about three hours to try to get
service and stuff and try to get help
I'll be back in seven hours
musical but before she left though she
did leave him with warm gear and
clothing
I hope she's good with direct
because where she goes gets help but she
was [ __ ] I forgot how to get there what
if she laid all the warm gear and all
that and [ __ ] like in the quicksand - if
Nikki was in the quicksand and she was
like you have to navigate back she'd be
like I know you're not gonna ever see me
again you will not be able to navigate
back here and I'll be like I know baby I
[ __ ] loved you so [ __ ] much
[Laughter]
no idea have a good back are you bad
with directions very bad
I'd probably and I'd probably do
something really stupid like drag a
stick behind me but then they all gets
covered up from a winter storm and then
I'm like well that's a goddamn [ __ ]
isn't it you're like sitting there with
the park ranger me like well it's fine
cuz it tracked it with this ticking but
oh my god it's [ __ ] raining oh my god
where did this come from like you feel
like trailing behind was saying like
don't worry I laid a trail of sand
behind me it's like [ __ ] we're in the
desert all argue is probably like
alright the last bit of food that we've
got I'm just gonna take pieces of it I'm
gonna make a trail so that I know how to
get back my following you I'm a don't
worry we're in the desert there's very
few animals and then it's all you it's
like a little quail that's like [ __ ]
following you finally a search and
rescue team began hiking to fan to find
the the man and woman by the way if you
want a solution take off your t-shirt
rip little pieces
tie it to things well what about your
your survival that's assuming it's not
cold
yeah death well if you yeah I mean a
daytime or is that multiple layers to
there multiple layers if not then take
off your underwear go commando to guy
that's not Orange
that would be way more survival you
[ __ ] up I should've died before I go
hike all these other chicks or injure
you guys spared Agra Bears I dude after
5000 men wear wigs have to fit that one
that's a hot [ __ ] look well if you
got IBS just take a [ __ ] every few miles
now you're bragging that's what dogs do
actually alright so then
search and rescue they found the woman
she was showing signs of hypothermia Oh
hold it and so they treated her then
several hours passed before the they
could find the man and so by the time
they found him he was described as
stable but suffering from exposure
hypothermia and extremity injuries why
they in the cold I mean it's cold so
they were saying that the man had been
exposed in water for ten hours and then
it took several more hours into the
night before his leg was freed because
it was the storm came in so he's in the
well so hold on so then one thing the
Rangers rewarmed and treated his leg
that's when the winter storm started and
it it brought four additional inches of
snow and so the Rangers and the man had
to spend the night at the site because
now they were stuck I hope they brought
camping things I'm sure they were
prepared I hope so you have a helicopter
so then that's when the next day once
the storm passed because they need to
have visibility that's when the
helicopter came Oh at least it was just
one day at least it feels good to have
more company like you've really guys
sucked at least I got two Rangers they
got him out what if one guy was like
panicky and he's like oh [ __ ] we're
gonna [ __ ] die and he starts like
killing people's logical question no
that was your last he's like oh [ __ ]
we're gonna be stuck here forever if
higher we're gonna pull sticks like why
yeah we just got here yeah it's like
there's enough rations that we have to
kill somewhere now dismember them now so
we have meat this thing kind of happened
to me we're a few years ago I'm Big Bear
this is like right after it was raining
so like any part of dirt that had any
part of dirt was like really really
mushy and the Big Bear Lake to kind of
try it up a little bit so while we're
waiting for the other party that I was
against this whole thing next to a cabin
we're just like what should we do I'm
like well the only logical thing to do
is to go off-roading and then since half
of the Big Bear Lake dried up from
my eyes I was like I'm just gonna drive
across the lake they'll be so [ __ ]
bad I love it so I'm right there i gas
the car I'm ready dog three years ago I
floor the car go wrong go right into the
lake and immediately just get stuck
because the thick mud right so my tires
are [ __ ] buried into the [ __ ]
apart putting reverse huh
just [ __ ] speeding like it's like my
doubt keep sinking yeah and I let that
dog I let the dogs jump out
mady's well let them run around you're
gonna go off ready with the dogs inside
yeah it's not like this it was just like
just a black dirt and then so the dogs
jump out and they immediately jump out
and sink it to the bottom
you know biggest [ __ ] truck this
these [ __ ] idiots in the middle and
we're just waiting right so then all
from a distance there's a bunch of docks
and the theme and the whole cruise they
finally get there and then it deems like
you know being the demon trying to help
us so he runs swish jumps off the dock
and then he immediately he sings in the
[ __ ] dirt up to here that's how deep
the mud was it was fine and then he was
thirty so all the guys are terrible he
loses a shoe in the mud Prezi is so the
tow truck people came so they're like
professional Big Bear like Torah people
right they called him a dummy so they
cut they he called me dummy he comes in
this [ __ ] crazy off-road looking Jeep
and he comes in he like he has like
these waders and he comes I'll go to me
hooks me with this metal cable thing and
the minute he turns the winch on which
is the thing that rolls the metal cable
back into the Jeep the Jeep gets pulled
into the butt - because my truck was
just so stuck and now his big-ass
[ __ ] tires are also in the mud and
then we have two off road cars in the
mud you have to call another tow truck
and this one was like super like dually
like monster look
so it has these so it stays on land and
then it puts like these two like metal
lanes so it's like a giant bipod and
then you have to run that to pull the
Jeep and then the Jeep to pull my car
they charge you fraud oh [ __ ] yeah have
to pay like $1,700 yeah dude well that's
for two companies yes yeah so I pulled
that thing that the important that's
illegal
to go into a lake he's like you you're
not allowed to drive to a lake and I was
like it's not a big fan it's that little
town yes that's where dumbasses were in
that thing are you talking about the one
that's on the left is a bunch of big
boulders yeah and then it's kind of like
there's homes around it I'm gonna
surprise the never knew this picture his
school passive you'll see my school
there's a vlog I do remember the photo
but I didn't know like to the extent of
this whole story yeah that is amazing
you are an [ __ ] dude that was awesome
like wasted like a long time we must
believe that there isn't a middle no we
had I love the childhood wonderment
excitement the idea of driving [ __ ]
[ __ ] facing don't do it no do it in you
and any that's us she probably didn't
even get 30 seconds it was
he was like oh [ __ ] and then keep going
reverse and then it kicks and it just
keeps sinking I'm like I turn over look
at her and she's already like I used to
have a really straight posture before I
got with him now a [ __ ] question mark
like yeah you know it's fine you know
what open the door and you could see the
dirt right there immediately I'm like I
foresaw this [ __ ] on the car I'm like
dirty your own selves I'm squishing them
the mud with me I want to know what
exactly Nadine thought he would
I see the funny thing you see do you had
to jump from the dock instead of just
walking in and going oh this is muddy I
can't do this trick though it looks
solid and then there's certain spot
spots where you press it and it's like
okay this is solid and then there's some
that you just sink you know like do you
ever like look at those like National
Geographic pictures were like the the
sand dirts all cracked
mm-hmm so there's parts of it when it
looks dry and cracked and then you step
on it goes right under his all mud is
it's a former lake so it's probably like
600 where the fish go dude you're lucky
you didn't just go all the way [ __ ]
in how would you even a better blog if
the mud was to the windows good title
and then I would have to climb through
the window that have been awesome at the
stem a popular fiction is [ __ ]
thumbnail for that I told Michael this
is it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]